Oh
does it go to the frames 3h HD video HD
vieng i like they're big and cheese i
wanted half gallon of milk at the store
and turn it into this as the look of a
two-day-old and bear do you use it or
Ganic no i did not enjoy anything fancy
from milks my first time i will go more
fancy after i do it once
urban radish down the street sells
non-homogenous goat's milk so that would
make a good cheese
and I will have the classiest presence
of anybody in my circle of friends and
we will see how it turns out in about
two weeks
I'm coming off of the exit which is
always super [ __ ] busy now I'm on a
motorcycle some [ __ ] they didn't feel
like letting me through and so they
pulled into me as I got up to the back
of their car they were pushing me into a
position where I didn't have anywhere to
go and I was going to hit the curb put
my foot down to get around them and the
back of my bike hit my foot and pushed
it forward and now I can't tell if I
broke my ankle if I just sprained it
really bad it's just where my tendon is
okay that's that's normal so it's like
right here yeah and that's
it's not sharp it's just like I put
pressure on it and there's dull pain I
call Jenna she she might know so I don't
know I don't know what to do really
cuz it looks worse whoa oh my god 50%
brighter than the light storm Ellis 1s
lights that you have well Bowens s mount
means you can put all your old photo
accessories on there so 1.5 K equivalent
so super freakin bright TLC I ninety
eight point four and then there's a
tungsten and a daylight and then a bio
head wise are two pins on this so you
stick that in right there tighten this
up and this will be your umbrella
vectors bother guys are releasing every
other day that's on the same an eco
channel yeah so the same remote that you
have for the other ones will work for
these two so you can have one remote
power these two turtles and you're like
stones all with one remote you can bend
them up yeah great at a single sorry so
you put those barn doors on there this
will cut you can get those hard lines
nice the big LED dude it's one giant LED
and they're that big
nice place except into the light ah one
of the things about the panel lights is
that so you can take your missed me by
Bowens barn horse the thing about multi
source LEDs is that we try to cut them
they don't give you hard lines yeah so
these ones will give you kind of those
hard shadows but you're looking for okay
give you a very beautiful shadow yeah
and then if you want of course the
beauty dish you know got all that stuff
on there love it not a hard yeah please
come out in a month to ship Enderman
like put your next to it to fans all
right now yeah it's pretty quiet so the
fans from the same place that Mac Pro's
get their fans oh really
yeah it doesn't burn me when I touch it
which is the big crazy part you know
yeah five eighty five eighty right so
first of all there's like no LED lights
on the market right now that go off
battery that are single source LEDs even
counting like the weird no-name brands
there's like four three tops and they're
all to grand oh yeah I know people like
some people complain about shiny barn
doors I've sometimes I go back and forth
sometimes I like to shiny sometimes I
like black which one off or prefer black
because at the end of the day if you're
going to use this to cut light and you
put it like this or like this you're
going to get a high light bouncing off
that onto your ceiling and that's
another thing to deal with the heat sink
works great being battery powered is
fantastic
let's say with a dial perfect yeah it's
also you want to be repeatable if you
made one of these you would sell one to
every red owner in America
oh dude it's for me and you
oh hey yeah thank you
I don't know why they put it in this box
don't say I don't love you Carmichael
there's that that